scp-1730 is one of the biggest threats
the foundation has ever faced
scp-1730 does not exist
it was june 5th when the compound was
first discovered a large complex of
structures in rural texas
about 15 kilometers northwest of the
mexican border located in big bend ranch
state park
it was easily the biggest structure in
the area but there was no record of any
such structure ever being built
a massive network of power stations
containment facilities
and research buildings scp-1730 looked
like it had been abandoned for a long
time
the exterior was degraded but the
building was still operating
a power generator had been running for
an indeterminate amount of time
even as the infrastructure degraded
power flickered through the site
and fuel leaked frequently but there was
one detail that attracted the attention
of scp brass
scp-1730 bore identifying markings
linking it to foundation
site 13 a research facility that was
marked for construction
near gnome alaska but site 13 had never
been built
having been abandoned in the planning
stages so why is it in the middle of
texas
fully constructed and long abandoned the
foundation needed to know more
and they needed their best to
investigate it was time to call in the
game wardens
apollo 3 the mobile task force used to
investigate dangerous sites was brought
in
and five elite agents were briefed and
sent in ross
houston noah ohalo and vigo it didn't
take long for them to discover that
something was very wrong with the site
of scp-1730
the facility was located in the middle
of south texas but the local flora
surrounding it was native to nome alaska
something had transported a building
that shouldn't exist to another place
and time
commander ross ordered his men to enter
with houston taking the lead
they discovered that the entry led down
a long staircase
they descended slowly following a
strange light that no one could identify
but had a sudden shock when they
discovered that the basement of the
staircase was missing
the light suddenly stopped and it became
so dark that it was impossible to see
what lay beyond the staircase
upon probing the inky black void at the
base of the staircase
they determined it wasn't a fog or
shadow it was a liquid
and it was rising ross ordered the men
to pull back but houston was in too deep
he couldn't break free from the inky
black liquid the men pulled him away and
got him free but his legs were gone
not ripped off because there was no
blood anywhere smoothly cut off
as if they were never there and as they
put houston down he stood up on
phantom legs he didn't feel any pain but
everyone could tell something was very
wrong with this place
and the messages they started seeing on
the wall made clear they weren't the
only ones who knew it
what happened to site 13 death here not
my body
bleed there had been other people or
things inside
scp-1730 and they wanted anyone who
entered
to know that this was a very dangerous
place to be as they advanced down the
hall back toward the entrance they saw
what looked like a person in the
distance
but as they approached it became clear
it wasn't another explorer
it was an old horribly disfigured corpse
seemingly attached to the wall
not by chains but views to the wall in
unnatural ways
at first the team seemed unconcerned
recognizing the corpse as someone named
zachary
fortunately command back at the base
realized this as the effects of some
sort of
cognito hazard a mental infection in the
base
they uploaded a filter to their helmets
and the team recoiled in horror
at the site in front of them but the
horrors were just beginning
they turned around to see a shimmering
humanoid entity in the hallway behind
him
as it approached its footsteps distorted
the hallway around it pulled ap-3 noah
toward it
without touching him and as the soldier
was pulled into its clutches
his body started to distort viggo was
next being grabbed by the arm by a long
appendage
and his arm started to change color and
distort but the foundation sent apollo 3
and prepared
houston produced a portable reality
anchor designed to handle reality
warping entities
and with a flash of red light the
creature was revealed it was a horribly
elongated humanoid that only existed for
a second before the reality anchor
erased it
and restored the hallway to its normal
state viggo would recover
with the strange red color in his arm
fading eventually noah wasn't so lucky
he was already dead had been fused into
the wall just like the unfortunate
corpse
these horrors had been encountered just
by trying to return to the entrance
so it was clear the only smart thing to
do was to descend
further into the facilities and get some
answers as they advanced
not encountering any other supernatural
entities they saw more evidence of the
dark things that had occurred in site-13
the infirmary had been torn apart a
cafeteria had been melted into slag
and a large group of containment cells
ended with a section called
olympia class but while most of the
other cells were standard sized
these were over 100 meters high what had
the foundation
or whoever ran this place been keeping
in these cells
they would get more answers as they made
their way down the hall where they saw a
single television still working
and illuminating the hallway at first
the television flickered but the image
soon cleared
and the agents were able to see what it
was broadcasting it was the interior of
a containment cell
and there was someone in it and they
recognized them as one of the most
dangerous beings contained by the scp
foundation
bobble the clown a predatory
supernatural clown
that inhabits a children's tv show
bobble the clown was broadcast by an
unknown source and could only be seen by
children under 10
originally seeming to be a normal kid
show about a clown
every episode eventually devolved into
the murderous bobble teaching kids how
to do horrible things
like arson and torture the foundation
eventually captured an isolated bottle's
broadcast
but the clown remained hostile and
vicious but not here
as the team talked to the bobble trapped
in the mysterious site 13
it became clear that this clown was
broken by whatever it had experienced
it rambled and hid from the camera and
it was clearly terrified as it told the
team about the horrors of the site
and it seemed to recognize the agents as
something familiar but not completely
familiar
it claimed to be able to smell them and
it said they smelled different
as bauble rambled on the agents learned
about a man named emerson
who ran the site like the foundation he
was obsessed with containing the strange
and dangerous entities in the world
but unlike the foundation he didn't just
want to protect the world from them
he hated them the entities in sight 13
didn't even have numbers
emerson wanted to use them up however he
wanted and to dispose of them
and something bobble called the meat
grinder entities that outlived their
usefulness were taken down below and
none were ever heard from again
it was directly counter to every scp
foundation policy
but this site had clearly been
performing these horrible experiments
for years
how and why hadn't anyone heard of it
the team continued to make their way
into the facility but their signals were
lost as they entered the cryogenics unit
by the time contact had been restored
they were no longer alone
there were survivors both agents of the
foundation
and survivors of the facility and they
were angry with no way out and massively
outnumbered
they called for backup mobile task force
t5
also known as samsara was reserved for
the heavy duty missions
they're an elite group of practically
immortal cyborgs fashioned from the
flesh of a god
and equipped with further cybernetic
enhancements to eliminate keter
level threats and to protect themselves
from cognito hazards
they were sent in through a drainage
gate to look for survivors and
neutralize whatever lay within
they didn't know what to expect but they
knew one thing no one who had been sent
in had come
out it wasn't long before they realized
how dangerous this mission would be
as they came across some large gated
drainage pipes they could see at least
20 charred bodies of humanoids pushed up
against the gate
some reaching their hands through
whatever had happened in site 13
these unfortunate beings had been
desperate to escape
as they made their way down the drainage
pipe they could feel it getting hotter
as if they were nearing an energy source
there was one other odd thing about the
pipe
it was draining inward not out they made
their way
into a control room where many of the
consoles had been destroyed
looking through a window their view was
obscured by a mysterious black mass
on the control panels they could read
terms like incinerator and
body pit access they split up trying to
find answers but found many of their
accesses blocked by the black mass
as the t5 task force argued over their
next move they were startled by a sudden
jolt
the giant mass had started moving the
team watched as the mass spun
revealing a giant turbine which turned
the inky substance into a fine slurry
that was then scorched by giant streaks
of fire
one of the t5 shot open the glass
chamber allowing the team to be closer
and blasting them with a wave of heat as
they descended into the chamber they
could see a massive plant-like structure
overhead
which started to shake suddenly
thousands of glowing pods were released
from the massive plant
and each one lit up and let the team
view the chamber more clearly
but it was what was inside the pods that
was more disturbing
each pod had a humanoid shape inside
seemingly reaching toward the team
until they hit the slurry below and the
shadows went dark the team descended to
investigate the slurry
when something started to leak out of
the walls looking at it they could see
something moving within
one of the team members picked up the
wriggling object out of the black liquid
and it took a bite of his hand it was a
leech and there were thousands more of
them moving toward the slurry consuming
it
and as the leeches ate they started
growing they seemed to be moving in
unison communicating with
a larger being lurking at the base of
the slurry a larger leech
a queen or something else the team
wasn't sticking around
to find out they beat a hurried escape
from the leech room finding themselves
in another hallway
whatever the black substance was the
entities who had been here had used it
scrolling blood on the walls over and
over again
occasionally they would come across a
drained corpse covered in the black
fluid
had the leeches bled them dry the
facility was so sprawling that the team
knew if they wanted any chance of
navigating it safely they needed to get
the lay of the land
they needed to find the control center
the door read stairs to cryonics and the
leeches were nowhere to be found
it seemed like a safe path but as soon
as the team entered the temperature
dropped drastically
to well below where it would be safe for
a human to survive the team's internal
heating system kicked in to save their
lives
but it wasn't the only threat the team
was about to encounter exactly what site
13 was keeping locked up
as soon as they entered the room sound
ceased to work
the filters in their gear were
overloaded and the team saw warnings
around the room
silence don't look a massive
multi-limbed figure emerged with each of
its 60 arms moving independently
the creature had no head but a large
circular structure covered with ancient
glowing symbols
whatever it was it was ancient
all-powerful and
deadly the team scrambled to get away as
the glyphs on the creature burned white
hot
anyone who touched it was burned anyone
who looked too long at it
felt their optical implants burn out the
symbols on the creature were
indecipherable but one word was clear
and printed in
english emerson site 13 was from another
world another timeline
where the scp foundation evolved into
something horrible ruled over by elliot
emerson
it tortured and captured its beings and
eventually killed most of them in the
horrors of the incinerators
when an escape threatened to destroy the
facility emerson successfully activated
the device
that removed the facility from their
world into ours of course as any avid
follower of the scp foundation will know
there's far more to the story than this
emerson may have been the start of site
13's problems but he was far from the
end
it's the mission of the century a daring
rescue into the depths of one of the
most dangerous locations in the
multiverse
site 13 otherwise known as scp-1730
when the impossible site 13 was first
discovered multiple mobile task forces
were sent to plummet's depths
and none returned they were greeted to a
labyrinthine nightmare
littered with deadly cognito hazards
escaped scps and mysterious murderous
leeches
some were trapped along with the
civilians they were sent to rescue
others were killed or changed in
unimaginable ways mobile task force
apollo 3
also known as the game wardens had been
sent in on a rescue mission when they
encountered a horrifying sight
the captured broadcast of bobble the
clown a dangerous scp known for
corrupting and destroying children
through its deadly messages
but this bubble was different much like
everything from site 13
this bottle came from an entirely
different dimension and he had
terrifying information to relay
in the universe where sci-13 originated
the site's psychopathic director one
elliot emerson had struck a deal with
the global occult coalition
a controversial government group who
intends to protect humanity
by killing anomalies rather than
containing them emerson had converted
his site into an unethical unrestrained
slaughterhouse
and was incinerating scps by the 100 in
the so-called body pit but emerson's
game of death came back
and bit him snapping the threads of
reality and turning the entire site into
a dimensionally displaced super anomaly
the game wardens realized they were in
way over their heads
their chances of surviving this place
were dropping by the second
and if they wanted any chance of
succeeding in their mission they needed
backup
so site command called in mtf tau5 aka
samsara
calling in samsara for a run-of-the-mill
collection mission is like using a
bazooka to kill a housefly
but for a case as severe 1730 their
skills were not only nice to have
but vital samsara are among the best of
the best
immortal cybernetic clones forged from
the flesh of a god
equipped with weaponry and technology
that could surpass even that of
other elite mobile task force units the
four members of samsara are so adept at
what they do they earned the nickname
power rangers among their peers
the remaining game wardens knew that
with samsara on the case
they may actually survive this thing
after all and they just needed to hold
out
samsara arrived on site not long after
packing some serious technological heat
including arm mounted incendiary cannons
shock absorbing leg extensions
heat resistant plating and built-in
scramble adaptations within their eyes
to ward off the deadly cognito hazards
everyone involved was in for the fight
of their lives the four samsara agents
irantu
nanku munru and onru entered via a
drainage gate in one of the office
buildings above ground and began their
descent inside
after observing numerous chart bodies
they deduced that there must have been a
massive incinerator somewhere on site
emerson's incinerator theorizing that
this was connected to the body pit they
kept hearing about
they descended further feeling the
temperature rise as they did so
due to the anomalous nature of 1730
nothing inside made any kind of logical
sense
caused by a reality warping machine
known as thresher
the internal geography of site 13 was
subject to constant shifts
the team then split up to cover more
ground moonro and nanku continued to
follow the pipes
and the heat toward the furnace while
irantu and onru broke away to explore
what lay beyond a weak wall
after busting through the wall irantu
and onru explored several empty office
blocks before finding their way
into a control room with a glass
observation deck while the window was
obscured by garbage and human corpses
signage indicated that the incinerator
and the body pit were directly below
them
the team once again reconvened and
managed to activate the incinerator
which shredded the mass stuck inside
with several large turbines before
burning the resulting slurry
the same process that had happened to so
many anomalies under emerson's watch
with the path cleared samsara decided to
descend via the incinerator
using the drainage pipe as a kind of
makeshift tunnel eventually they
happened upon the leeches
large black and hungry these creatures
seem to infect 1730 by the thousand
anywhere that blood or drainage runoff
could be found the leeches could be
found
too they didn't appear to have any
connection to an anomaly previously
secured and contained by the foundation
they squeezed and wriggled through the
cracks in the walls searching for fresh
blood
on root detected that the leech is all
moved with a kind of collective purpose
suggesting a telepathic hive mind onru
was able to tap into this hivemind using
her cybernetic enhancements and mapped
the chaotic geography of 1730
through the leech colony's collective
knowledge with this new advantage
they could add a second goal to this
rescue mission find the thresher device
causing
all the instability and potentially
reduce power to it if possible but they
were on the clock to save the other
survivors as those leeches were sure to
get hungry for warm blood
soon they followed the leeches down the
most direct path toward the survivors
on the way they encountered a horrifying
creature the many limbed humanoid
nightmare that functions as emerson's
eternal punishment
his charred body tied screaming and
alive to the platform where the
monster's head should be
they managed to make it past the monster
before finally rendezvousing with
captain hollis of mobile task force 8-9
otherwise known as the mole rats as well
as the game wardens and the other
survivors
there were 27 surviving members of site
13 staff
many of which had severe injuries making
it even harder to transport them back to
safety through the hazardous terrain
and to make matters worse the leeches
were back the team quickly decided that
the best route out of here was directly
past the thresher where they could
reduce power to the machine for just
long enough to create a stable path of
escape nanku opened fire on a horde of
approaching leeches with the
flamethrower and everyone began running
for their lives
it was a final make-or-break dash to
safety however their advance was soon
stopped by a strange roped creature
drawing a cognitohazardous meme on the
wall with its claws when the team
attempted to engage it attacked
exposing additional deadly memes and the
dangerous effects of its single white
eye
and we're not talking about internet
memes here these are symbols and
information that are often deadly to
even bear witness to
and for you or i this would be a real
threat but not to a team equipped with
goggles containing cognitohazard filter
technology
the battle was cut short when the floor
collapsed underneath them and the
creature was devoured by something even
larger and more monstrous
a gigantic black bleach covered in huge
red eyes
its entrance caused thousands of leeches
to spill out into the hall
as the monster screeched and slithered
its tentacles after
them allow us to introduce you to elijah
also known as the leech boy
and a pivotal component of the very
existence of scp-1730 he was a boy with
the mind of a toddler but he had the
strange ability to absorb blood through
people's skin
hence his nickname leechboy one of the
doctors in site 13 dr hadley took pity
on elijah
after all he didn't choose to be the way
he was director emerson didn't share
hadley's sympathy his orders to
exterminate all anomalies included
humanoids like
elijah when hadley protested emerson had
her beaten within an inch of her life
while other dissenters were shot dr
hadley disgusted by the inhumanity of
her superiors devised the perfect
revenge
she sabotaged the incinerator and the
body pit allowing a mass containment
breach that flooded the site with deadly
anomalies
young elijah ended up consuming the
slurry of the other shredded anomalies
causing him to mutate into a powerful
monster
a behemoth of a leech who gave birth to
and controlled all the others
it was hadley's revenge that caused
emerson to panic and activate thresher
leading to a rift in reality in the
creation of 1730 and by extension
all the problems faced by our heroes
today samsara and the others fled leach
boy
began taking a different escape route
however while on route they encountered
the dreaded crystal butterflies
a dangerous scp capable of destroying
organic matter with a mere touch
irantu stepped up to bat roasting the
creatures with his arm mounted
incinerator
and taking extreme damage to his body in
the process but they didn't have time to
rest with the butterflies disposed of
they kept moving
heading toward the thresher but not all
the scps were necessarily working
against them
bobble the clown came in handy at the
next checkpoint manifesting in the
monitor of an electronic door
and opening the way through as they
continued on their journey they had to
fight off frequent attacks from leeches
losing some of the task force members in
the process they were also forced to
face off against a number of other
anomalies in order to survive
such as scp-2316 manifesting his
floating bodies beneath them
and scp-1370 which used a huge
mechanized body to attack the team of
survivors
that was all just a warm up for the true
final battle though
the floor shattered beneath them and out
of an impossibly huge
chamber the monster that had once been
elijah wriggled free
reaching for them with huge tentacles
and shrieking from its thousand-toothed
maw
it was at least 200 meters tall and
barely reacted to any amount of
firepower it seemed like they were all
doomed until captain hollis had a truly
crazy idea
with the help of samsara she led the
bloodthirsty abomination down through
the cryonic center and into an olympia
class
testing chamber there as the leech boy
was bearing down and then hollis opened
the gates to two adjacent containment
cells and something beyond incredible
happened
two of the most powerful scps ever known
a giant sword-wielding gate guardian and
the reality-bending cosmic deer scp-2845
entered the arena what followed was one
of the most epic showdowns in the
history of the scp foundation
as the deer and the gate guardian went
to battle against the all-devouring
leech
while the monsters fought hollis ordered
her team to get the rest of the
survivors to safety
she and monroe of the samsara team
remained behind to prevent any of the
anomalies from escaping
as the entire base began sinking into
the ground from the combined forces of
the battle raging around them
and the thresher's continued onslaught
on reality even if the survivors escaped
would the anomalous developments inside
site 13 escape and wreak havoc on the
world at large
that's when hollis received a vision a
horrific charred post-apocalyptic world
roamed by inconceivably powerful
entities and nightmare gods
it was a vision so horrific that just
seeing it nearly broke her mind
she knew what she had to do the only way
she could truly defeat this terrible
place and ensure safety for mankind
while leech boy the gate guardian and
the deer continued their battle for the
ages
hollis ran to thresher and forced the
machine into overdrive
up above the remaining members of
samsara the mole rats and the game
wardens escorted the survivors to safety
downstairs thresher emitted a blinding
white light as the system began overload
in her final moments all hollis could do
was laugh
perhaps it was a laugh of pure insanity
of a mind broken by the horror she
witnessed or perhaps it was a laugh of
victory
knowing that in spite of the immense
powers all around her she had won the
day
she had saved not only the survivors and
her teammates but possibly
all of humanity and all it cost her was
everything
outside the survivors had reached a safe
distance away when the entirety of site
13 imploded in a final brilliant flash
when the dust cleared scp-1730 was gone
all that was left was an immense crater
where the impossible base should have
once been
captain hollis had done it through
overloading the thresher machine she'd
taken this anomaly out of the world the
exact same way it had entered it was
torn from its moorings on our earth and
kicked into the infinity of space-time
perhaps never to be seen again along
with everything it contained
scp-1730 was reclassified to neutralized
of course the foundation would have
plenty of other anomalies to pursue soon
after but the nightmare of emerson's
site 13 was over
once and for all
a light shines above a metal table with
a chair positioned on either side
this is the isolated hermetically sealed
interview chamber of provisional site 23
outside the room awaits two
shell-shocked human mobile task force
members
another with invisible ghost legs three
powerful cyborgs
and a scientist from another dimension
they're all here to talk about one thing
the nightmare that unfolded at site 13
also known as
scp-1730 everyone thinks they know the
story a mysterious site suddenly appears
in texas
seeming to exactly match the blueprint
for an abandoned site that's supposed to
be in nome alaska
what started as a simple anomalous
location turned out to be an epic horror
from another dimension
the task forces sent in by the
foundation were either massacred
or trapped inside and those who survived
reported seeing unspeakable carnage
inside the base
including a death machine designed to
destroy anomalies
and that's not all as a result of the
mysterious thresher machine the entire
location had been transformed into a
shifting spatial anomaly
filled with creatures straight out of a
nightmare from giant telepathic leech
monsters
to huge multi-limbed demigods that would
eternally punish the site's murderous
director
elliot emerson it was only through the
combined might of three different mobile
task forces
including the legendary samsara and the
sacrifice of brave captain hollis that
the cursed location was finally flung
into a different dimension
neutralizing the threat it posed to our
reality but for the scp foundation the
story doesn't end with neutralization
there's still plenty more questions that
need answering
and that's why today we're going to tell
you what they found out after the
neutralization of scp-1730
not only will we discover what's become
of the many people involved
we'll learn about what happened in the
last moments before the neutralization
took place
and perhaps most importantly of all for
the sake of our universe
we'll find out how site 13 came into
existence and how site director emerson
went down such a dark path
it's time to get some answers welcome to
the final part of the scp-1730 saga
as we close the book on one of the most
deadly locations in the foundation
multiverse
first to sit down in the interview chair
was captain ephraim ross
leader of the mobile task force apollo 3
also known as the game wardens
he was a shaken man looking far older
than his 35 years
his eyes heavy with the weight of the
horrors he'd seen and he and his team
were among the first to venture into the
bowels of site 13
and witnessed the atrocities that had
gone down there like the body pit full
of fleshy
slurry or the countless containment
chambers that mark their occupants for
vivisection
and termination captain ross was haunted
by the things that happened to his team
under his watch as the anomalous
transformation of houston's legs
and the nightmarish warping death of
noah at the hands of a stretchy reality
bending anomaly
he compared the state of chaos going on
down there to something like jurassic
park
where all hell had broken loose and the
monsters ruled he also remarked on the
olympia containment cells each the size
of a football stadium
capable of containing things far beyond
the scope of this universe's scp
foundation
his interviewer was the hard-nosed dr
peter vincent who thanked captain ross
for his contributions
and called in the next interview subject
agent lea mahalo a game wardens task
force member
working under captain ross he had a
thousand yard stare
and even the untrained observer could
see that agent ahallo had left some
parts of himself back in site 13.
when dr vincent attempted to interview
him he mostly remained silent
only volunteering one grim statement we
should have died in there
this isn't real this isn't real we were
supposed to die in there
next to be interviewed was captain
irantu of mobile task force tao5 aka
samsara
his interviewer dr isha saint claire
questioned him about the nature of the
mission
and the cybernetic soldier was even
keeled about the matter he said that in
spite of regrettable losses of life he
was still satisfied with the outcome of
the mission overall
the high value targets were rescued the
anomaly was for all
intents and purposes neutralized and the
degree of loss was actually better than
their pre-mission predictions
it seems that the weight of death
doesn't weigh quite as heavily on those
who will probably never have to
experience it
as the samsara team are capable of
simply being rebooted into new
bodies if terminated in the field people
like captain hollis weren't as lucky
next agent connor houston of the game
wardens was both interviewed and
medically evaluated by dr ian harris
agent houston had his legs
dematerialized after he tripped into a
rising tide of anomalous liquid
which he described as looking like a
moving physical computer glitch
however in spite of this agent houston
is still able to stand and move of his
own free will
it seemed to dr harris that houston's
legs were somehow trapped between
dimensions
houston told dr harris that he didn't
experience any kind of pain when his
legs were removed but to this day he
occasionally feels something furry
brushing up against them
perhaps wherever his legs are they
aren't alone
next the stoic agent moonroof of samsara
was interviewed by
captain eliot o'neal of mobile task
force d26
also known as time cops captain o'neill
had a bone to pick with moonroo
namely that he'd allow captain hollis to
run off and sacrifice her own life
despite having a clear directive to
prevent the human task force members
from endangering themselves at any cost
moonroo deflected claiming that when
hall is separated from the group
he assumed that she ran off with
intentions that never included her own
demise
o'neill and the foundation found this
answer unsatisfying and decided to move
on to their next interview with onru
the last person with captain hollis
before her death the interviewer dr
darian arnold probed the elite samsara
operative on why she turned off her
camera
before she and hollis reached the
thresher the machine that hall is
overloaded to annihilate site 13 from
our dimension
she gave a more compelling answer than
moonro when she and hollis entered the
server room on the way to the thresher
they encountered what might have been
the ultimate cognitohazard
it was a vision of a terrifying
alternate dimension with billions dead
a poisoned star like the biblical
wormwood fell from the burning sky
a nightmare god like the one torturing
elliott emerson wandered along the
fields of crucified people
covered in deadly cognito hazardous
ruins just looking at it burned the
scramble technology out of moonroof's
eyes
and she quickly turned off her cameras
to avoid potentially frying the brains
of mission control
hollis wasn't so lucky the things she
witnessed broke her sanity and when she
finally overloaded the thresher machine
she was
laughing and crying finally and perhaps
the most enlightening debriefing
interview of them all
site director william vesterlin
interviewed dr mohammad scott
the highest ranking researcher of site
13 and confidant of the now
infamous director elliot emerson the
question was simple
just what had happened for site 13 to
become so messed up
and dr scott answered in detail with the
tale of corruption
alternate realities and the perils of
unchecked power
in his home dimension site 13 was
originally created in nome alaska to
house the corpse of a giant sea creature
that beached itself on the border of
india and bangladesh in 1964.
it became the largest and most secretive
foundation containment facility in the
latter half of the 20th century
however disaster struck in 1994 when a
marxist extremist used an anomaly to
level the willis tower in chicago
as a result the foundation lost a lot of
its funding and international support
leaving it in dire financial straits
enter the true villain of the site 13
story
paul manafort if that name sounds
familiar to you
it's because he was an associate of
president trump in our universe
who got into legal trouble for shady
international dealings however in dr
scott's universe he was a powerful
staffer for president bob dole who in
that reality had beaten bill clinton in
the 1996 presidential election
manafort was made the new secretary
general of the global occult coalition
the un's answer to the scp foundation
and one of their leading competitors
with an ethos geared toward killing
rather than containing anomalies
manafort and the goc co-opted the
struggling foundation providing them
with money in exchange for control
the foundation had no choice but to
accept the deal with the devil
slowly manafort replaced the foundation
old guard with toadies and loyalists
the ethics committee and the o5 command
were dismantled dissenters were dragged
out of their offices and shot
point-blank in the head execution style
site 13 had originally been directed by
dr
bright but bright was arrested and
contained under false pretenses
so manafort could install a new director
a mid-level researcher by the name of
elliott emerson
emerson is often painted as a sadistic
monster who took pleasure in torturing
anomalies to death
and flushing them down the body pit the
reality is both
simpler and more grim emerson it turns
out was just an eager yes man
he was put into his position to follow
manafort's orders to a t
and those orders were simple kill in a
perfect example of the banality of evil
dr emerson converted site 13
into a brutal slaughterhouse just as his
overlords at the goc had ordered him but
things were quickly getting out of hand
and one of the most vocal critics of the
new regime was one of emerson's old
lovers
one dr vera hadley assistant director of
anomalous biology
dr hadley was disgusted by the inhuman
acts emerson was carrying out
and couldn't stay silent and for this
she faced horrific consequences
corrupt guards stripped her and beat her
to within an inch of her life in front
of her co-workers
in that moment she swore her revenge she
sabotaged the containment procedures and
had the engineers rigged the already
unstable thresher device to overload
as emerson watched the anomalies break
containment he began to fear for his
life
both from the anomalies themselves and
from the punishments of his superiors at
the goc
dr scott revealed that emerson was no
evil mastermind
he was a lap dog for the goc a dirty
coward all the way to the very end
and he was desperate he held dr scott at
gunpoint and ordered him to activate the
thresher or die
and the rest is history there would be
no redemption for dr scott's former
friend as emerson ended up chained to
the rune-covered platform head of a
nightmare god
for all eternity so ends the debriefing
of the site-13 survivors
and closes the book on that terrible
place for now anyway
the story of scp-1730 is anything but
simple
and there are so many angles from which
this dark tragedy of cruelty and
corruption can be approached
and ultimately it was all for the same
two things at the root of every evil
the desire for money and power but the
pursuit of these base desires can lead
to some truly nightmarish consequences
and nobody knows this better than former
director eliot emerson who will be
paying for these sins until the end of
time
and perhaps even beyond now go check out
another epic tale from the scp
foundation
scp-5000 the suit